tu es jarrige des lunettes même je peux
à oui oui oui ou c'est non on pense que
c'est beau hein jean marie le pen me
poser pour le font tourner au sommet de
l'aiguillé du midi dos au mont blanc ça
ne change des bassesses de la politique
habituelle 1 auquel vous ne contribuent
jamais jamais jamais je regarde les
mousses donc malgré la rivière qui l'a
vu prendre celui des gens marine va se
prêter à un jeu de cache cache et tous
ceux qui résident le plus connu de
chamonix et loire mur ne s'est pas
montrée même pas de la messe à laquelle
jean-marie attristé
est ce que vous avez pensé une seconde
voire edouard balladur n'ont que deux
indépendants de gestion edouard balladur
était sérieusement je pense pas qu'à ça
alors qu'elle avait convié jean marie
lebel à chamonix ce week-end une course
auto